rocket launcher in one form or another
has been around to the best part of a
millennium from its humble and unstable
origins in ninth century China through
to its explosive appearance in some of
our favorite movies video games these
ridiculous armaments have made quite the
impact but how exactly did this one
thousand year old explosive tool become
one of the most quintessential of all
video game weapons to start our story
reading to go back 1,000 years to the
birth of gunpowder to where the fuse of
today's Rockets first caught spark in
the mid 19th century Taoist alchemists
accidentally discovered a basic form of
gunpowder while trying to create a
potion for immortality the alchemists
called their new creation fire medicine
but as you can probably imagine it was
pretty far from anything the grant
eternal life especially since it often
ended up burning down many of their
homes the Taoists alchemists wasted
little time adapting their fire medicine
to create flaming arrows by attaching
small pouches of gunpowder to the base
of an arrowhead some years later this
design was refined so a more potent
compound could be used to introduce more
of an explosive reaction this was then
used in everything from fireworks sent
into the sky to ward off evil spirits to
bombs intended to repel the invading
Mongol hordes the early history of
firearms is kind of bound up with
rocketry and in fact at that time they'd
probably be regarded as the same thing
and you see the term firearms used to
cover handguns or portable guns and also
well basically any firearm hence the
name so they're attaching canisters of
gunpowder to hefty arrows and launching
those at the enemy setting people's
stuff on fire setting them on fire which
is fairly horrific thing to consider and
the other effect is fragmentation so
it's a little bit unclear at what point
that iron cases start to be used but by
the late 18th century in India
we know for sure I in cased effectively
fire arrows or basic rockets essentially
a bomb on the end of a stick that is
being fired at the enemy the
psychological effect is often sort of
remarked upon and that's that's still a
thing even today when it comes to
missiles and rocketry all these
developments were documented in the
Wolong Jing or firedrake manual which
was a 14th century military instruction
book intended to be a guide for all
things fire weapons involving gunpowder
either way the experimentations would
continue with Chinese weapons myths
creating peculiar creations such as the
nest of bees which was a handheld
launcher capable of firing 34 arrows at
once often poison tips there were also
cart based launches that could fire
anywhere up to three hundred and forty
arrows and bore incredible names like
the chariot of fire or the hundred tiger
rocket launcher there also exists the
legend of a Chinese minister who
attached rockets to a chair ignited them
and disappeared in a smoke but it
doesn't go on to say if he took off or
exploded into smithereens outside of
China one of the most famous ancient
rocket based weapons is the Korean
Watcher which was used extensively in
Korea's defense against Japanese
invaders between 1592 and 1598 one
account of the battle was reported that
3,400 Koreans repelled 30,000 Japanese
with the help of 40 watches these
watches had a range of up to 2,000
meters and cast out a wide spread of
arrows so they were naturally a perfect
weapon against the densely packed
Japanese samurai and infantry the
British Empire learns from this chap
called Sir William Congreve adapts this
technology and creates a sort of bigger
and better version of it using the power
of the Industrial Revolution behind them
to create essentially batteries so just
as you've got cannon wield cannon field
guns you've now got artillery batteries
that shoot rockets and so that that's
another another string to the military
bow since the creation in the Far East
generals and tactician have fallen in
love with a humble rocket and the rocket
launcher would go on to see deployment
across history from the Congreve rockets
of the Napoleonic era to world war ii
shoulder-mounted explosive munitions
which were a necessity to contend with
the advent of vehicular warfare the
Americans entrance the rocket launcher
race was the bazooka so named due to its
resemblance to the popular 1930s musical
instrument of the same name but the
shoulder-mounted explosive version sung
a much angrier tune it was among the
first generation of infantry born
anti-tank rockets and allowed for
high-explosive anti-tank rounds to be
utilized against the powerful
German Armour in the European theater of
war during the conflict in Africa and
along the Eastern Front Germany captured
an inventory of bazookas and iterated on
the weapon improving its design to
create a competing German launcher named
the panzerschreck or tanks bein world
war ii is one of the most documented
periods of history in films TV video
games with many films about the war
released in movie theatres before the
conflict was even through this media
served as propaganda for the war effort
and showed folks at home the daring
deeds of their heroes overseas of course
the many weapons moviegoers saw them
using onscreen heroics became synonymous
with them and gained popularity too
while old school action comics newsreels
and movies helped cement these weapons
into the public consciousness it was
through the medium of film the rocket
launch have really exploded into the
realm of pop culture and as the film
industry matured and developed over the
decades each movie tried to one-up or
outdo the action in the entertainment
that preceded it movies tapped into the
primal lust for bigger booms and more
badass heroes with films like Rambo
first blood and Terminator 2 and
predator helping to define the era of
action cinema where bigger bangs meant
for bigger bucks at the box office
I think the pop culture aspect of
rocketry is really the spectacle so the
same reason that we like to pump these
things into the air and watch them
explode is the same reason we like to
see them punted it the bad guys and
explode it's something bigger and better
yet by the 1930s we're used to seeing
gangsters running around with tommy guns
automatic fire we'll start to see the
first war movies and they're throwing
hand grenades the militaries of the
world readapt rocket technology and used
on the battlefield so certainly World
War 2 onwards we start to see things
like the bazooka recoilless weapons like
the RPG come in and they're just a way
to add value to add enjoyment on the
entertainment side of course they're not
fun to get shot out by needless to say
and never far behind a hot trend it
wouldn't be long until video games
starts to put rockets into the hands of
their players be the accurate
representations science fiction fact
similes or esoteric Lampoon's it's fair
to say that the gaming market
immediately found their new favorite toy
2d sprites would become a common sight
in side-scrolling shoot-'em-up Slyke
Metal Slug but it was when games entered
the third dimension and FPS titles
became the new hotness the players
really got to feel the visceral roar of
a rocket launcher the incredible
popularity of the first doom in 1993 not
only helped popularize the FPS genre but
the weapons that so handily dispatched
demons on the surface of Mars also got a
taste of that same fame from that point
on any FPS worth its salt would have to
have those most satisfying tools of
destruction things like impactful
shotguns huge multi barrel mini guns and
of course the rocket launcher were no
longer a bonus but a requirement this
meant that the hordes of games that
would release in the wake of doom each
trying to tap into that same acclaim
that its software shooter had garnered
would need the same suite of diamond
dispatching tools and with a rocket
launcher being the overwhelming
crowd-pleaser it became a mainstay in
videogames players around the world sunk
hour after hour into mulching enemies
into Gore and jibs and all while the
popularity of the rocket launcher would
only continue to rise not content with
helping to popularize the rocket
launcher its software also wanted to
experiment and innovate with how far
they could push the boundaries of their
rocket propelling boom tubes as they
entered the arena shooter market with
1996 is quake they've turned a tool that
was solely used to detonate Cacodemons
into one that could be used for
traversal alongside the requisite wanton
destruction
rocket jumping is a technique that
combines the force of the Rockets
explosion with the players jump together
the two create a burst of speed and
height allowing access to new areas and
strategic opportunities in some games
this would come with the downside that
the player would take some damage
creating a kind of risk reward to the
technique its use spread throughout
quakes player base which certainly helps
shine a spotlight on the mechanic and
added a new way to play in a growing
arena shooter genre an alongside the
quake series the rocket launch even made
appearances in epics Unreal Tournament
and Valve's Team Fortress 2 even today
the rocket launcher and the rocket jump
remain embedded in the culture of gaming
tying itself so closely to the DNA of
video games as both a blessing and a
curse to the rocket launcher over the
years as game genres changed gamers
taste matured and titles moved to new
directions so too did the weapon that
becomes so integral to the DNA of an
action-packed shooter in 1999 Steven
Spielberg took to writing games hot off
the success of directing the 1998 epic
Saving Private Ryan he went on to write
medal of honor the world war ii FPS that
would be instrumental in guiding the
direction of shooters for years to come
with its cinematic set pieces of axes
armor versus allied explosives Medal of
Honor and many of its sequels were
enormous successes and that success
birthed a whole trend of world war ii
shooters
titans of the industry were forged in
the fires of a virtual Normandy with
Medal of Honor leading the charge and
huge franchises like Call of Duty and
Battlefield eventually falling in
alongside them but in each World War two
epic the inclusion of adrenaline-pumping
set pieces and the ebb and flow of
vehicle and infantry based combat we're
beginning to become a must and while
previous FPS games were able to have
massive bullet sponge bosses with
ridiculously large health balls the new
era of 1940s militaristic shooters
required a more mature and realistic
climax to their missions many of these
games would feature tanks and armored
personnel carriers as the insurmountable
obstacle for the on-screen GIS to
overcome and as such the rocket launcher
would be called in to fill another role
and the virtual battlefield
[Music]
this would define a trend that would
become consistent for the use of rocket
launchers in video games whether a
series featured vehicular gameplay and
needed an explosive counter or a sci-fi
game needed a big boom to overcome its
climactic alien menace the rocket
launcher would always be part of the
virtual Arsenal there in a different
class there literally in a different
class we call them light weapons in the
sort of NATO system so small arms light
weapons they are usually crew-served
usually requires more than one person to
maybe one person can carry them and in
the movies and certainly in the games
you're the only one carrying them
they're big they're powerful they're
loud especially with things like the
Hollywood depiction and the videogame
depiction of the RPG that sort of iconic
white trail you know you know dangers
coming it's a great sort of cue to the
audience or to the gamer to get the hell
out of the way because something big is
coming that will take your health way
down so it's like a gun but more so
naturally as a multiplayer games became
popular some adjustments would need to
be made
given the power and destructive
capabilities of the rocket launcher the
term throw pipe was often used with
frustration as a salty response tossed
out whenever players were dispatched
with an RPG or a t-4
in call of duty modern warfare 2 for
someone on the receiving end
they undeniably felt too powerful and
perhaps unfair but the same time rocket
launches are a necessity since their
primary role was to counter the aerial
killstreaks that would rain down on the
battlefield balancing the Boomer rocket
however has always been a tricky
business when it comes to its prevalence
in multiplayer games battlefields for
example shreds the line of having them
being much more deadly to vehicles and
armored targets than they are to
infantry while halo treats the rocket
launcher is a rare but extremely
powerful commodity that must be fought
over and it's small ammo pool used
sparingly the rocket launcher is a
weapon that in games elicits as much
laughter as it does shouts of anger it
always draws an emotional response
whether it's branding fellow players and
noob Shuba or a pro Piper or cheering
through your headset as you squad up
with your team and take down an enemy
tank in battlefield it's caused laughter
as Spartans ragdoll across Blood Gulch
and confusion as enemy soldiers fall
from the sky in Team Fortress 2 yet
what's most impressive about the rocket
launcher is that not only has it
descended from an invention over a
thousand years old but that it adds such
variety to a videogames arsenal it's
like the virtual Swiss Army knife of
blowing things up it's been co-opted and
adjusted and remoulded to fit an insane
number of titles and franchises but it's
always recognizable and it's always
exciting regardless of the genre taste
or direction a game might take the
rocket launcher has always had a place
in the action whether it be the tank
destroying bazooka the over-the-top
demon slayer showering blood and guts
over a hellish battlefield or the
futuristic m41 of the Halo franchise
scattering grunts like the pins at the
end of a bowling alley the rocket
launches versatility is no doubt
impressive
it's a weapon that's tied itself so
deeply into videogame history by
appealing to something primal more than
a saw the love of blowing stuff up
I hope you enjoyed this look at one of
the most iconic and explosive weapons in
all the video games if you did be sure
to like the video subscribe and join us
again next week for a brand new episode
of loadout